this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out Squarespace
through the link in the description
below more on them in a bit it's one of
the most chilling passages in military
history
in the 13th century secret history of
the Mongols Genghis Khan's quartet of
elite generals are described thus they
are the four dogs of Temujin they have
four heads of brass their jaws are like
scissors their tongues like piercing
oils in the day of battle they devour
enemy flesh behold they are now
Unleashed and they slobber at the mouth
with glee coming from an empire as
bloody as the Mongols these passengers
fairly drip with horror but even among
the dogs of Temujin one stands out as
more cunning more sadistic and more
terrifying than the others his name is
subbu Ty Genghis Khan's
dog of war a non Mongol who joins the
Khans tribe at age fourteen simatai
blossomed into a master of battle the
Mongols greatest general sibu ty road
further and conquered more than any
other man in history it was thanks to
him that Russia was brought into the
mongol falls that the mongols reached
central europe that they came this close
to taking Vienna yet despite being both
brilliant and vicious subbu ty is now
mostly forgotten in today's video we're
looking back it's the greatest and
deadliest general to ever live
[Music]
although you would become the Mongols
greatest general suet I was never
destined to be one of Genghis Khan's
people when he was born
rounds 11 75 ad it wasn't on to the
endless plains of the Mongolian steppe
this into the dense dark forests on the
western shores of Lake Baikal his tribe
were the early ank I sometimes
inaccurately known as the forest Mongols
inaccurate because the rank I had almost
nothing in common with their southern
neighbors where the Mongols could ride
night and day the Erlang high used
sledges where the Mongols were masters
of weaponry the Ariane Kai were better
known for their metalwork but that's not
to say that the two had nothing in
common
every year when the snows finally melted
the Mongols and the URI yang high would
meet to trade it was during one of these
meetings that Sigrid eyes fate was
sealed the story goes that subitize
father often traded with a Mongol known
as yesugay the subitize dad wound up
owing yasugi a favor and promised him
his firstborn son 18 years later the
Ariane Chi trader returned to the step
with subitize older brother yell Mei in
tow ready to fulfill the bargain but
when he reached the Mongol can be
discovered that yesugay had died many
years before in his place was now his
son the outlaw Temujin rejected from his
own clans a moochin was a nobody at this
time but a deal was deal so yama joined
him not sixteen years later tomaron
would acquire a different name
Genghis Khan and llame would make sure
that his younger brother got to join the
great khans conquests sadly this neat
origin story may just be that though a
story a fiction but what is true is that
llame for whatever reason wound up
joining Temujin around 1187 just three
years later he invited his younger
brother subbu type superhigh was by now
a fourteen as was the custom he was
supposed to train and his father's
business become a blacksmith and take
over as the man of the house but subbu
ty clearly yearns for adventure for a
life like the one that Jame was leading
out on the endless romantic plain so in
1190 he left the yeren Chi behind
he abandoned
the thick forests of his ancestors and
headed south to where the action was boy
what action it was in 1190 Temujin was
just setting out on the path that would
soon see him unite the mongrels butts
aboot i wasn't yet a fighter he still
needed to learn the skills the mongols
valued in a warrior luckily his brother
was by now one of two merchants most
trusted advisors jomi ensured sobota got
the chance to learn horsemanship how to
ride day and night non-stop and how to
survive the alternating Ice and Fire of
the Mongol plane by 1197 Siebert I was
ready for battle for his first
assignments he was to help Temujin wipe
out some long-term rivals back then the
Mongol step was still a fractured
collection of tribes who enjoy nothing
more than bashing one another's heads in
and making off with their wives
what are these tribes the markets had
done exactly this a while back with
Temujin zwei fans now Temujin never
missed an opportunity to attack them
only this early version of Genghis Khan
wasn't just a Russian and Kelvin guy he
preferred stuff like spies and
infiltration and that's house aboot I
came to appear in the market camp
claiming it defected from Timon in
offering his hosts intelligence on his
former tribes movements market
apparently being Mongol for gullible
buffoons the tribe believed him and
sweet hide led them right into an ambush
they were subitize first serious taste
of blood and it certainly was not going
to be his last
[Music]
while Genghis Khan is mostly remembered
today as a conqueror he was also a great
innovator one of those innovations was
the idea of promoting his generals based
on skill rather than kinship it was this
enlightened policy that would allow the
non mongaul su butai to rise to the very
top
not the progress was fast in Samoans
clan you earned your stripes the hard
way through years and years of constant
bloody warfare sympathize early
adulthood was spent doing stuff like
helping unite the Mongols culminating in
1206 with two Mugen being proclaimed
Mongolia's universal ruler or Genghis
Khan he was part two of the subsequent
assault on the shyah shyah Kingdom the
first time the Mongols fought as a
united force outside their homelands
importantly he was also part of the
gigantic war the Mongols undertook
against the great Jin dynasty of
northern China we say importantly
because it was during this epic war that
su boot I showed the first glimmerings
of the great general that he would
become in 1211 Genghis Khan cooked up a
plan to deliver an early body blow to
the Jin armies with a surprise attack
subitize role was to lead an army of
30,000 towards Jin territory from the
north when the Jin forces masked Genghis
Khan would attack with a larger force
from the west smashing them apart first
the plan worked Siebert I rode down from
the north paraded his army around all
the while doing his best to look
nonchalant the Jin took the bait masked
their forces and then were duly
surprised when Genghis Khan came
charging into their flank but then
things started to go wrong the Jin put
up an unexpectedly strong fight refusing
to give grounds then subitize army
vanished from the field allowing the Jin
to focus on Genghis Khan had super tide
just bottled it had he fled since this
video isn't titled tsumetai that dude
who ran away from battles you can
probably guess the answer to that one
question rather than flee sabot I had
rode south hard pushing his horses to
the limit now his army was swinging back
up north circling around the Jin coming
at them from behind the Jin never knew
why there was simply no way Zubat I
should have been able to ride that far
and that fast yet Harry was suddenly
leading thousands of Hmong
girls in a surprise attack from the rear
it's a mystery whether
Sibu tying Genghis Khan plans this
before hands or whether suet I took a
gamble in the heat of battle
either way the sneak attack made
possible only by an impossible ride
would become a Cebu Thai hallmark over
the next few years the Mongol conquests
rampage Don in 1214 the Djinn were
driven out of their capital of Zhang do
now Beijing and the city burned to the
ground
five years later in 1219 Genghis Khan
attacked the Central Asian quarries M
Empire beginning a war that would see
his Empire stretched from the Caspian
Sea to the Sea of Japan
not that Sibbett I would witness this in
1221 Genghis Khan's selected as loyal
general for a special task as the war
raged on in chorus mere Sabbath I would
take 20,000 cavalry west on a
reconnaissance mission it was the
beginning of a process that would soon
see Mongol hordes sweeping into Europe
and destroying everything in their path
it was also the beginning of subitize
rise from mere general to the greatest
Conqueror in all of history try to
picture just for a moment what it must
have felt like to be in Eastern European
in the early 12 20s up till now your
comfortable world view has essentially
extended no further east than Jerusalem
China and the Far East a vast blank
nothing's where you suspect no humans
really live and then it happens
the first Mongol raiding party comes
sweeping through the caucuses and Ivan's
your backyard bringing unprecedented
devastation in their wake it must have
been the 13th century equivalents of a
Martian invasion and Sibbett I was the
mighty Martian warlord the speed of his
invasion was shocking in 1222 subitize
army reached Georgia where they wiped
the floor with their army that done they
pushed West reaching Crimea by early
12:23 it was at this point Europeans
first made contact with the empire that
would nearly destroy them as they
reached Crimea subitize army had sliced
their way through the nomadic humans but
the Cuban leader had managed to escape
and had gone running to his
son-in-law prints missus laughs of
galley and gallic in 1223 just so
happened to be a part of the fabled
Empire of Kievan ruse the forebears of
modern Russia Ukraine and Belarus the
princes of Kievan ruse were a loose
alliance ooh together one of the
greatest forces of Europe so when mr.
Slav heard about these barbarians
hammering at his gates he forged a pan
Russian army to go and teach them some
manners at first sabbatai seems to have
realized that it made a mistake
his forces fell back from the vast
Slovak army for nine whole days the
princes of Kievan ruse chased the
Mongols east they chased them all the
way over the Kalka River now thought to
be the couchy critter in Donetsk Oblast
in Ukraine finally in late May Prince
mr. Slav forced a battle his forces
attacked the Mongol rearguard
and naya lating them as the panicked
Mongols retreated over the river the
Prince followed determined to finish
these heathens off once and for all at
this point
scimitar presumably gave a truly
terrifying smile it had been a trap of
course the moments the Russian armies
were pins with their backs against the
river
the Mongols stopped their retreat turned
around and well that was it for the
princes of Kievan ruse it's estimated
that 90% of the ruse force was
annihilated 40,000 soldiers 17 nobles
and 6 princes fell before subitize sword
among those captured was the prince of
kiev who suffered the worst fate of all
rather than simply kill him CBI arranged
Aven placed on the floor wards on top of
which the Mongols held their victory
party a night of a thousand men
frantically dancing atop him was enough
to slowly crush the Prince to death yet
this would be the finale of subitize
first journey West despite the damage
that unleashed the Mongol army was a
mere twenty thousand strong far too
small for a serious campaign of conquest
so after a journey that had taken them
8850 kilometers from their homelands or
about the distance from anchorage alaska
to bogota Sibbett Ollie and his men
turned around and rode home you can
almost imagine the relief in Europe as
this unstoppable new threat receded a
slow exhale of breath as people realized
that they weren't doomed after all
but this was dangerous miss reading of
the situation Sibbett I might be gone
but he hadn't forgotten those who tried
to fight him he would soon return when
he did it would be game over for Europe
and just before we return to today's
video I do want to take a moment to tell
you about today's sponsor Squarespace
now two simple things maybe you've got
an idea for a website or a business that
you want to start or maybe just a
podcast or a YouTube channel something
like that well the only way to figure
out whether that's something good is the
second thing and that's to put it out
there into the world and I know that can
be a little bit daunting because you
know it's scary to go and pursue new
things but not knowing how to set up a
website is not an excuse there are no
excuses available with Squarespace
Squarespace allows you to create a
powerful website for whatever you're up
to you want to sell something online yes
easy to set up a store with Squarespace
or a podcast sure they handle that or a
YouTube channel well you want the
website to complement that you know
somewhere else for people to go to learn
about you it all starts on Squarespace
with a beautiful template that you can
customize to your heart's content or you
can start from scratch or you can easily
move over from an existing to mean
making everything super easy to manage
but don't start from scratch just use a
template like I said it's all about not
having any excuses with Squarespace and
once you've gone through the super easy
customization process there are no
updates there are no patches there's no
tech BS the after deal with Squarespace
also hands a long event or web sanity
stuff like I said they do podcasts but
they also do you know mailing lists
social integrations all of that website
e stuff plus they've got 24/7 customer
support who are there to help you if you
got a question after squarespace.com for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to Squarespace com forward
slash via graphics and you'll save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain and let's get back to it
for the next 13 years Sibbett I stayed
near Mongolia witnessing the Empire
transform first came Genghis Khan's
death in 1227 followed by the elevation
of his son
Agha died - leader then came the
consolidation of power as organ I impose
taxes and bureaucracy on conquered
peoples as all this was going on Mongol
ambitions stayed small although it was
in this period that jin northern china
was finally smashed more remote
conquests were postponed finally though
the Empire was stable enough that Agha
Dai told sir but I to head west again it
was music to the old war dogs ears by
now the legendary general was a man of
sixty his days of riding were over and
had grown so fast that he has travel in
a carriage yet the tactical genius that
had served him so well had only improved
with age when Civet I would return to
Europe it would not be on a mere
reconnaissance mission that a full-blown
campaign of conquest incredibly in the
13 long years since the Mongols first
appeared Europe still had not got its
defences sorted the Russian princes were
busy squabbling amongst each other and
while a united force might be forged it
was gonna take a while so sabotage
simply decided that he wouldn't give
them even a spare second to think about
it that senior 1236 the Mongol army
crossed the Volga River its head was
nominally bow to Kahn grandson of
Genghis but the one in charge of
strategy in charge of terror tactics was
sibert I and if there was one thing so
but I excelled at it was terror the
first year of the invasion was spent
mopping up the semi nomads of Europe's
Far East the Volga boggers the Kip
checks the islands as one by one year of
satellite tribes fell subitize sent
ambassadors to the princes of Kievan Rus
telling them to surrender without
resistance or watch their whole world
burn when the princes refused we can
only imagine subitize smiled his
terrible smile on the 21st of December
1237 the city of rise and some 200
kilometers from Moscow became the first
to fall to subitize forces women were
dragged screaming through the streets
children were shot full of arrows and
thrown into burning buildings men were
disemboweled well their families watched
at the end of the slaughter rise
was no more only a handful were left
alive spared by subbu ty so they could
spread the tale of his savagery it was a
tale that would soon require many more
chapters after Oz and the Mongols moved
northeast columnar fell then Sue's doll
then Moscow yet even as Moscow burns the
Russian Prince's still couldn't
coordinate a defense still couldn't
forget that petty rivals long enough to
defeat the dog of war on February the
7th 1238 the war dog fell upon the city
of Vladimir it's Grand Prince Yuri the
second fled the carnage assembling an
army to fight back
he returned to the smoking city only to
get pinned down by a blizzard as EURion
des army waited for the weather to lift
they wondered where the Mongols were if
they were hiding to the north to the
east or somewhere else entirely finally
the storm lifted enough Yuri to send out
scouts they came back with a horrifying
answer the Mongols were hiding to both
the North and the east and the west and
the south the 200,000 strong army had
completely surrounded the Russians in
the subsequent battle Sibbett I
systematically slaughtered the entire
Russian army at its end he had Yuri
dragged before about UConn and ordered
to kneel when the Grand Prince refused
his head was sliced clean off by April
12 38 Sibbett I had done the impossible
hid invade in Russia in Windsor did 112
cities were in ruins the northern
principalities had been laid to waste
but this incredibly this was just his
warm-up act before support I was done
the whole of Europe was going to cower
before him
[Music]
in late 12:40 the first Mongol warriors
were sighted from the walls of Kiev in
those days Kiev was the center of the
Orthodox faith one of the three great
cities along with Rome and
Constantinople of Christianity well that
was the case until December the 6th
anyway that day the mongols breached the
city walls everyone inside was killed
leaving such a pile of corpses that the
streets were still littered with bones
nearly a decade later yet Kiev's fall
was just the opening salvo for the next
act of subitize invasion subitize plan
was to attack the kingdom of hungary
home to one of Europe's greatest armies
but rather than just go charging in he
split his forces into sending 30,000
north under a warrior named kaiju
it was kaijus forces that torched Krakow
and drew the citizens of Rodd Slav into
flight
it was Qaeda's forces who killed the
Silesian King Henry the pious and so
effectively destroyed his army that they
were able to fill nine sacks with the
severed ears of the dead but it would be
Sibbett i alone who annihilated hungary
in spring of 12:41 Sibbett i divided his
forces into four columns and marched on
the kingdom as this angel of death
approached king bela the fourth summons
an army 100,000 strong they amassed on
the swollen shores of the danube just as
subitize party appeared but if Bella
thought he had the situation under
control he was badly mistaken as he
marched out east to fight the small
among ghulami fell back they retreated
for nine whole days until they had
crossed the one small bridge over the
wide unfor double-size river if this
sounds familiar it's because these are
the exact same tactics which I had used
against the princes of ruse nearly two
decades earlier but Bella wasn't an
idiot he waited across the stone bridge
refusing to take the bait daring Mongols
to come to him so they did on April the
11th 1241 the Mongol force attacked
across the bridge at daybreak although
the Hungarians were taken by surprise
they weren't broken they managed to
rally it even looked like a Hungarian
victory might be on the cards but if
Bella had had any advisors from Jin
China they would have been able to tell
him what a grave mistake he was making
they would have been able to ask the
quest
that would soon doom the whole of
Hungary where was super high it turns
out the general had found a way to Ford
that unfortu ball river they were all
fighting on making one of his trademark
impossible cavalry rides to crossfire
some far-off marshlands now 30,000
bloodthirsty mongrel Warriors were
bearing down on the Hungarian flank
their teeth bared war dogs just ready to
devour their prey the impact shattered
the Hungarian army as the Mongols closed
in salute I kept a gap in the ranks
almost daring the enemy to escape it was
an obvious trap but the panicked
Hungarians had no other option they fled
through until a column of screaming
terrified refugees was pouring off the
battlefield their weapons discarded
finally when the army was in complete
disarray the trap sprang shut two
columns of fresh mongrel horsemen
appeared charging down the fleeing
soldiers one by one they were
slaughtered and the soldiers were all
dead the mongrel forces then rode into
nearby villages and put everyone to the
sword by the end of the massacre up to
70,000 Hungarian bodies lay strewn
across the plain with them had fallen
Europe's last great line of defense
there was now nothing between the
Mongols and the Atlantic nothing between
sobota and the complete conquest of
Europe but the old war dog would never
get to fulfill his dream
the Mongols would never conquer and he
thought the Western hungry even at the
pinnacle of his tribe subitize war days
were nearly over
[Music]
the early winter of 1241 was spent
teaching the Hungarians a bloody lesson
civet i rode from ends to end of the
kingdom destroying any settlement in his
path Buda and pest were both burned the
town now known as erst gone went up in
flames
by the time December came it's been
estimated that up to 50% of Hungary's
population had been massacred and still
subitize thirst for blood had been
quenched as that dark December of 1241
gave way to a january that was bleak and
grey the mongols began to push west
again subitize and a column down into
northern italy and instructed
reconnaissance units to scout the danube
valley all across europe petrified
people's waited for the hammer to fall
as Mongol Raiders were spotted from the
walls of Vienna it must have felt like
the continents time had finally come
and then subitize army just stopped as
Europe watched and trembled the Mongol
armies halted their advance fell silent
for weeks on end at the ends they
suddenly packed up turned their horses
around and incredibly unbelievably they
rode back home today what caused the
mongol retreat is a source of
controversy the main theory is that news
of Agha daikons death on December the
11th 1241 finally arrived necessitating
a long ride home to help elect the new
Khan however there are other theories
linked to the miserable weather that
decade or the unavailability of food and
famine stricken areas but whether it was
protocol or rain turned back the Mongols
did it said so what I didn't want to go
that the dog of war gnashed his teeth
and begged her to finish his mission the
thing that he was born to do
but battle Khan ordered him and like a
good dog with its master Zubat I
eventually obeyed not that the ride back
was exactly peaceful on the return
journey the Mongols swept down through
Croatia Bosnia Albania and bulgaria
doing their usual slaughtering on the
fringes of Central Asia battle Khan
stayed behind
established the golden horde the
Carnot's that would be one of the
world's great powers for centuries but
these were just distractions post
scripts to the great adventure it was
time to go home now time for the story
to end
at last after arrived many thousands of
kilometers long Siebert I returned to
Mongolia as though his life of adventure
gave way to a singularly unaddressed
oh sure he was still respected when a
Franciscan monk visited the mongrel
caught in 12:47 Sibbett I was
practically royalty one year later
though in 1248 see what I drops out of
the historical record one story says he
spent his old age helping to raise his
grandchildren another says he
accompanied one of his sons back west of
the Golden Horde where he lived out his
last days on the fringes of the
continent it once come so close to
conquering the date of subitize death or
even how he died is unknown but what's
not in doubt is his legacy it said that
super ty in his long career conquered 32
nations that the lands distance he
covered with these conquests was nearly
ten thousand kilometers enough to put
any other great Conqueror to shame
Alexander the great Julius Caesar
Napoleon all these guys are mere pygmies
next to super ty yes it was a sadist a
killer bloodthirsty maniac yes he used
his gifts and the service a brutal
empire but Sibert I was never destined
to be a great thinker or artist he
wasn't made to be a peacemaker so what I
was built to accomplish one thing only
to fight to fight so hard that hit
become the greatest warrior the world
had ever known on that counts at least
the old dogs succeeded
[Music]
so I really hope you found the video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe also please do check
it off antastic sponsor Squarespace who
I'm linking to you below and thank you
for watching